Do you have any other hobbies outside of a comedy?
And,
um,
I'm not a big hobby guy.
Growing up,
my parents always used to say,
the lady,
what are you interested in doing it?
So I gotta be happy now.
Yeah.
And I'm like,
Holy Shit,
look,
you worked out.
My hobby is a standup comedy.
Really.
I mean,
um,
I like to cook,
don't get me wrong.
I like to travel.
Um,
my wife and I really,
really enjoy going to different places.
And,
uh,
I love hotels.
It's a,
I mean,
these aren't really hobbies.
It's just a,
I like hospitality.
So that's my,
that's my passion.
Uh,
I like having people over at the house and I'm making them feel good.
That's,
that's what I like to do.
I like to entertain.
Um,
if I find out you like a specific drink or you like something that's,
uh,
you know,
I,
I take,
I take notice of what people like.
So when you come to my house,
I got what you like there.
That's very talent.
It's very,
very Italian.
And,
um,
I've always had,
I,
you know,
I worked for the Four Seasons Hotel and a,
that chain taught me to anticipate people's needs.
So anytime I have anything at my house,
whether it be a birthday party,
it get together.
If it's going to be a fight,
I make sure when you come over you are taking care of not only with your alcohol
needs.
Here's one.
I ain't a punt gay.
Right.
I don't,
I don't smoke pot.
We want to start.
I listen,
but I ain't got pot at the house just in case you want some really.
So I thought,
you know,
you have alcohol,
you have beer,
you have scotch,
you have wine.
Right.
So what if,
what if someone doesn't have a taste for alcohol and they want a joint?
Wow.
I got a couple of joints where you get it from PDC,
from the comedy store.
I think I got it from,
you know,
from,
no,
I think it's a,
what's the Med med men.
Yeah,
men.
Yeah.
I went in there.
He went in there specifically just for hospitality.
Hospitality.
If you came over and I go,
Joe,
you want to join?
And you're like,
hey,
you want to smoke?
No,
I don't smoke.
You know there have edit just to have even a cigar.
I got to say,
God,
I don't smoke cigars.
You want one?
I,
I dunno,
I get,
I get joy in making others happy.
So when you looked at your house,
did you look at your house and go,
this is a good house to entertain in?
Ah,
yeah,
we see that like when you see like a youtube video on a home and they're showing
the homes.
So a wonderful entertainers,
home,
entertainers,
home.
What does that mean?
A Sanger guys playing the piano.
It was,
I mean I like,
I like a living room that bleeds into the kitchen.
All right,
that's,
I like that,
right?
There's not really a a,
a wall in between the two.
It's got to be,
and then I like indoor,
outdoor.
He live in California.
I like to go outside.
Maybe you want to have a drink outside and bring it back in.
Like the different,
that's what they want.
That's what they're talking about.
When it's a in there,
I like a fire outside.
Oh,
fire,
fire pit,
fire pit.
Do you try to bring people,
like if you have a party,
do you try to bring people over that you think would have interesting
conversations?
Yes.
Um,
although we have a problem at this particular point,
we're in a transition period.
Um,
we have a child,
so I don't know if you went through this,
but a lot of,
uh,
sometimes when you're coming from on a single couple but a couple with no kids
and now you have kids,
now you're,
you're finding other people who have kids,
right?
So that's what we're in.
We're a,
we're not yet into the preschool.
Uh,
so we're kind of in limbo.
We're looking for new friends,
right?
That are old friends are,
are bad.
It's just now we have other obligations.
We have a child.
We can't,
we maybe can't go out at the dinner at eight o'clock at night like we used to
now.
Now we're looking to bring it to the house.
Yeah,
no,
I know exactly what you're saying.
We went through that exact same transition and a lot of times you pick up some
dead weight along the way.
You run into these people and the only thing they have in common is the kids are
the same age and then they'd have to talk to some fucking guy.
Oh.
And they give you ear beatings about their job and just like you,
just some people just not interesting.
It's unfortunate.
Yeah.
I mean you do run into that where you meet a guy,
like I went to a toddler group,
uh,
last week.
Now some,
sometimes I do this obviously because I want to hang out with my daughter.
But sometimes the material that comes on at going to something like that is
gold.
Now it's me,
15 women and a gay guy at this toddler group.
Right.
So I mean it's just like,
it's almost writing if that writes itself,
although I'm in a,
in a circle sitting Indian style,
hey,
it's,
it's strange,
but man,
it's,
that's the things I want to do because I feel if I live more of my life,
I could draw so much more humor from it.
And it's,
it's a,
it's,
it's two pronged.
It's,
I want to hang out with my family and I want to,
I don't want to talk to people who are living in these life experiences because
what I've noticed is I want to keep the same kind of lifestyle I've had when I
wasn't successful because I feel that when you start detaching yourself from the
daily routine,
let's say,
even going to target,
if you have somebody go to target for you,
you don't,
you miss out on like what happens on a day to day.
And I want to still keep that rich and,
and,
uh,
available to me.